yes dr. Wallach how you doing fine sure
thank you how can we help you you have
two questions one is for my son he has a
he was diagnosed with a mixed receptive
expressive language disorder
he just can't grasp the English language
so he's having a lot of difficulties in
that area and the second one is for me
okay I mean listen I run away from your
son yet how old is he is I 10
he'll be a levitating mark okay does he
speak Spanish or German or Russian I
mean no he its primary language is
English okay
all right then yourself I speak English
no no no I mean what's your problem Oh
sometimes when I sleep depending on what
side I sleep on I get numbness in my arm
all the way down to my fingertips I just
want a relatively healthy other than
that how much you weigh
I weigh 200 okay I'll tell her you 5 not
okay and how old your son is 10 years
old yeah and you go okay okay sure man
you're there I'm here I'm here
what do you think's going on with some
earnest son who's 10 years old he's he's
having a language problem and you know
if this gets to be extreme it can be
called nonverbal where they just don't
speak they're so confused about language
they just don't speak at all nonverbal
you see this a lot in things like autism
and a DD and ADHD so what would you what
do you think's going on with that kid
and my opinion I would say he's got a
gluten intolerance and he's not
absorbing yeah exactly how much does
your son weigh 80 pounds 80 pounds okay
what would you give as a boy there
charmagne to get the nutrients into him
and what what would you do for his diet
well he gotta get on a gluten-free diet
no we barley rye oats and then I for
those issues I give him a healthy brain
and hard pack and I would add the
synaptic to it absolutely and of course
seven eighty pounds I'd read like a
hundred pounder and give him one health
abandoned hard pack per month divide
everything in half
and dosa breakfasts have a dosa
dinnertime and course adaptive the raw
materials for the brain cells to make um
these chemicals so they can speak to
each other so the brain cells can speak
to each other neurotransmitters so I'd
have them take two of those tablets
twice a day be one bottle of months of
the synaptic and then how many aids
would you have that kiddie today now
probably about four ok forks with
breakfast to dinner time you can put
them in a shake we have a slender FX
shake don't mix it with water because
you'll lose weight what you want to do
is make it with heavy whipping cream and
then throw two or three eggs into
breakfast and two or three eggs and
again at dinnertime haven't take those
shakes made with the heavy whipping
cream and the eggs in it
twice a day and then make sure he stays
away from all the bad foods no sugar no
fried foods and processed meats no oils
and no gluten will we burn around